من جنبي قال وزير الدفاع الالمانيه له لم
يتم اتخاذه اي قرار خلال اجتماع الحلفاء
الغربيين في رامشتاين بشان تسليم دبابات
ثقيله لاوكرانيا
وكانها متحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه قد
قال ان بلاده لم تربط ابدا تسليم دبابات
ليبرد لاوكرانيا بارسال واشنطن دبابات
ابرامز
اما الموقف الروسي بشان تزويدي كيف
بالدبابات جاء اعلى لسان المتحدث باسم
الكربلاند متر بيسكوف الذي قال ان صراع في
اوكرانيا يتصاعد
ويتزادوا معه خطر التدخل المباشر
فما صحه نيته لن تحدث تغييرا جذريا في
مسار المعارك لكنها ستزيد من المشاكل في
اوكرانيا كما ان تزويد اوكرانيه بدبابات
الثقيله سيكون له تاثير سلبي واضاف ان
الغربه سيكون واهما اذا اعتقد انه سيتمكن
من تحقيق النصر في اوكرانيا حسب تعبير
يعني